die europäisierung sozusagen der
arbeitslosenversicherung ganz genau ist
ein kleiner passus schön versteckt im
wahlprogramm der spd auf seite 57 ist
nicht so überraschend eigentlich dass
die spd damit kommt denn sie wollte 218
schon mal dieses projekt nach vorne
schieben damals olaf scholz als
finanzminister der immer noch ist und
jetzt kanzlerkandidat möchte eine
europäische arbeitslosenversicherung es
gibt den vorstoß aus frankreich unter
anderem aber das problem ist immer wenn
europa etwas machen möchte eine
gemeinsame kasse einen gemeinsamen topf
entsteht eigentlich der regel immer
schon fest wir bezahlen muss nämlich die
deutschen und genau so haben wir es hier
auch wieder diese diese arbeitslosen
versicherung ist angelegt für den
krisenfall dass länder die in eine
schwere krise geraten mit hoher
arbeitslosigkeit dann sich aus diesem
europäischen topf bedienen können in
diesen europäischen topf sollen aber
alle arbeitnehmer eines natürlich auch
die deutschen jetzt haben wir eine sehr
sehr niedrige arbeitslosigkeit ein gut
funktionierendes system
wir haben löhne die angemessen sind wir
haben eine gute arbeitslosenversicherung
also die frage ob die deutschen aus
diesem topf profitieren die kann man
ziemlich klar mit nein beantworten und
es geht also am ende wieder hier um
klassische europäische
umverteilungspolitik ist ein
unverschämter griff in die kassen der
deutschen arbeitnehmer der hier passiert
und man muss jetzt einfach mal
vorstellen erlebt jemand in saus und
braus beispielsweise vierten dickes auto
macht tolle reisen verliert er seinen
job und punkt dann den nachbarn an der
die ganze zeit geld zurückgelegt hat der
ganz normale sache ich mal gelebt hat
und punkt diesen nachbarn an und sagte
mir geht es gerade nicht gut jetzt musst
du für mich bezahlen da würde jeder
sagen unverständlich das ist
schmarotzertum und genau das passiert
hier auf europäischer ebene man muss
sich das vorstellen es gibt länder
spaniens beispielsweise mit der
arbeitslosenquote von über 16 prozent
das bedeutet aber dass dann deutsche
arbeitnehmer dafür dann zahlen sollen
ist dass die übersetzung ist die
übersetzung es geht um die richtigen
krisenfall es geht darum dass ein land
richtig in die krise gerät das sind 16
prozent arbeitslosigkeit noch nicht
genug dann würde man eher sagen
wahrscheinlich 20 25 prozent es geht um
echten schock aber die idee ist wie du
beschreibst genau richtig und man muss
sich immer fragen warum soll denn ein
warum sollen die arbeitnehmer aus
deutschland beispielsweise für verfehlte
finanz und arbeitsmarktpolitik in
spanien mit zahlen gibt's doch gar kein
grund die spanier problem selbst lösen
so wie beispielsweise deutschland
probleme auch selbst gelöst hat
stichwort agenda 2010 das war für sehr
viele arbeitnehmer sehr schmerzhaft das
war ein sehr wichtiger prozess aber wenn
wir sehen dass es jetzt
rekordbeschäftigung gibt und warum
sollen dass nicht andere länder auch
machen warum sollen die deutschen die
durch einen harten reformprozess
gegangen sind denn bitte länder oder
arbeitnehmern andere länder bezahlen die
diese reformen verweigert haben ist
nicht zu erklären und deswegen ist diese
diese dieser vorschlag natürlich
komplett abzulehnen ist ein griff in die
taschen der deutschen arbeitnehmer
[Musik]